اذا ليست اف 16 وحدها بل مجموعه من
التحركات والمواقف التركيه قد تضعها خارج
النسخه الجديده من لائحه اصدقاء روسيا
قريبا رئيس لجنه الدفاع والامن في مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي فيكتور بوناريف اكد تحول
تركيا من دوله محايده الى دوله غير صديقه
مندليف اسفه لاتخاذ انقر قرارات استفزازيه
بالاسابيع الماضيه واصفا سلوك التركي
بطانه في الظهر وخطوه غير وديه التصريحات
الروسيه تعقب زياره الرئيس الاوكراني
لتركيا قبل ايام وتاييدها محاوله اوكرانيا
الانضمام الى حلف النيتو كما اثار حفيظه
الروس اطلاق سراح قاده الكتيبه الاوكرانيه
التي دافعت عن مجمع في ماريوبل رغم
الاتفاق على بقاءهم في تركيا حتى نهايه
الحرب
ردود وافعال اطلاق سراح قاده كتيبه ازو
الرئيس الاوكراني خلال لقائه اردوغان
عائدون الى الوطن من تركيا وسنعيد ابطالنا
معنا
الافراج جاء نتيجه ضغوط شديده من حلفاء
انقره في حلف شمال الاطلسي
روسيا العقبه الوحيده في طريق تحقيق سلام
عادل ودائم نتعهد بدعمك افطالما تطلب
الامر
الخارجيه الفرنسيه على روسيا ان تدرك انها
تمضي في طريق مسدود ويجب ان توقف حربها
العدوانيه غير القانونيه
[موسيقى]
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات